l'équipe de france de parachutisme dans
la place le pilotage sous voile vous
connaissez c'est ça
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
un saut très rapide qui prend
certainement moins de temps que de plier
la voile avant de remonter dans l'avion
sauter encore et encore pour faire
toujours mieux
moins connu que d'autres bleus ces
hommes là sont vice champions du monde
par équipes
là on a une ossature dur et ça c'est
l'équipe type qui va discuter toutes les
compétitions internationales de
référence
et puis derrière on est en train de
faire de la détection puisque le pôle
france à il existe depuis deux ans donc
on fait de la détection dauphin de
continuer à avoir un réservoir pour
fournir les équipes de france des
champions de londres motivée par la
passion
guidés par les sensations
[Musique]
il existe trois types de sault vitesse
distance et précision repères et gage de
sécurité
la pièce d'eau et ses deux grosses
boîtes
on saute 3 4 secondes de chute libre en
anglais par passager faire le travail se
fait sous le parachute en gros faut
pouvoir juger les conditions
aérologiques et suivant des conditions
aérologiques de pouvoir se mettre à
l'endroit où on pense être le mieux pour
pouvoir faire notre virage notre virage
c'est ce que vous donnez de la vitesse
la vitesse qui a fait qui va nous
permettre d'aller le plus loin possible
en distance le plus possible en vitesse
et en précision c'est il nous faut juste
la vitesse demandé pour arriver à faire
c'est 90 mètres dans la zone demandé
cédric champion du monde de distance a
pris un congé sans solde pour participer
au stage ses nombreux succès
internationaux lui apporte un énorme
sourire on gagne le prestige le maire
n'en ont gagné ya absolument pas
d'argent en jeu
on fait vraiment sa peau au plaisir ça
demande beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
d'entraînement mais c'est vraiment c'est
notre passion donne tout ce qu'on a pour
pour ça et on s'entraîne vraiment pour
ça et c'est l'amour l'amour du sport
5000 l'hôtel site du pôle france de
pilotage sous voile terrain de jeu idéal
pour les spécialistes qui se sont
d'ailleurs donnés rendez vous du 7 au 9
septembre pour les championnats de
france
[Musique]